canta adiós a la cólera obstinada del
hijo de pelé o el noble aquiles esta
cólera infausta que ocasionando
innumerables males los saqueos precipitó
las almas generosas de tantos fuertes
héroes al oscuro imperio de hades
dejando sus cuerpos empresa
a los buitres
[Música]
y a los perros
así
el supremo zeus lo quiso
con estos versos de homero aprendían a
leer y escribir los niños griegos pues
os imaginais intentando deletrear
palabras como cólera
oscuro imperio seguro que no
reconocían su significado pero quedaron
impregnados por su magia
nosotros los de mi generación
aprendimos con mi mamá me ama
mínima y en este afán de dulcificarlo
todo incluso ahora andan intentando
cambiar los textos de los cuentos de
hadas no vaya a ser que se traumatizan
con ese lobo de grandes fauces
cambiar el contenido de la literatura no
es ninguna novedad se ha hecho muchas
veces a lo largo de la historia
censura y manipulación
han estado presentes siglo tras siglo y
han llegado hasta nuestros días
qué quiere la censura quiere mensajes
políticamente correctos versiones
simplificadas y manipuladas de la
realidad que favorecen un punto de vista
no es de extrañar no es por casualidad
que la poesía que favorece la curiosidad
el espíritu crítico la inquietud por
analizar la información que nos llega
haya ido desapareciendo
la poesía que lo era todo todo se
contaba a través de los versos
hazañas gestas leyendas de dioses de los
reyes de los próceres de los pueblos en
cualquier lugar en las fiestas en los
mercados en las ferias a través de la
memoria prodigiosa de todos esos
narradores ambulantes que generación
tras generación
las mantuvieron vivas para que llegaran
a nosotros
pero todo eso acabó hace mucho tiempo
que los niños no aprenden a leer en los
versos
y creo que ni siquiera ahora
se aprende algún poema de memoria en la
edad escolar
dejadme que os pregunte recordáis algún
poema nos vienen a la cabeza algunos
versos
si os vienen a la cabeza aseguró que los
aprendiste jce en el colegio
sí no
dejadme que os diga y aunque no
recordéis en un poema hay mucha poesía
en vuestra vida
incluso a pesar de los datos según el
gremio de editores a un tercio de los
españoles no le interesa la lectura
y de los que leen cuántos diría es que
la enp o 'si a
un 40 un 10 un 20%
sólo un 12 por ciento de los lectores lo
son de poesía
y aún así aunque no seáis los lectores
de poesía
hay mucha poesía en vuestra vida
la encontramos en el lenguaje cuando
decís que alguien tiene un pico de oro o
que está en la flor de la vida cuando
exclama es que tendréis que esperar mil
años para conseguir una vivienda o salir
de vuestra casa vivir solos
pues sí espero que no tengamos que
esperar mil años para cambiar ese 12 que
hemos visto
me decía el poeta juan vicente piqueras
que él no tenía muchos libros en su casa
pero creció rodeado de poesía porque
cuando acompañaba a su madre a veces le
decía hay que sofreír la cebolla hasta
que pierde el orgullo
o cuando salían al campo su padre le
decía hoy vamos a ir donde duerme el
agua
qué bonito verdad
hay mucha poesía en vuestra vida aunque
no seáis conscientes
encontramos en ámbitos que podríamos
decir que no tiene cabida la economía
john buck él es la persona que
revolucionó el mundo de los fondos de
inversión y siempre llevaba consigo un
poemario de serie porque
porque si el soneto que dedicaba
ozymandias
a la estatua en ruinas del faraón ramsés
segundo esa estatua semi enterrada en el
desierto
le ayudaba a recordar que debía ser
humilde porque nada ni el poder en la
mayor de las riquezas
duran para siempre
pues si hay ciencia queréis pueden
compartir algo estas dos disciplinas
comparten un componente de intuición que
hace que a veces se salten las reglas
para conseguir resultados inesperados
estamos en esta sala darwin y no sé si
sabréis que darwin era en su juventud
ferviente lector de poesía le gustaba
los sonidos de shakespeare le gustaba
milito le gustaba se lee
y nos dice en su autobiografía que a
medida que fue haciéndose mayor y se
alejó de la poesía
fue mucho más infeliz
imaginaos está en todos estos sitios y
también está en las redes se han
inundado de poesía incluso poetas
anónimos que dominan el tuit se han
hecho con miles de seguidores han
animado incluso las ventas de los libros
está en el lenguaje en la economía en la
ciencia vive una nueva vida en las redes
y aún así la gran mayoría de la sociedad
ni se plantea acercarse a ella la ven
como algo inalcanzable
abstracto aburrido que no van a poder
entender cuando realmente es todo lo
contrario
hacía ts eliot que la auténtica poesía
puede comunicar mucho antes de ser
entendida
y eso por qué
porque estamos preparados estamos
programados hay una intuición profunda a
reconocer su música a amarla
y si la alimentamos nos puede aportar
muchísimo
no sé si os habéis encontrado alguna vez
pues en la situación de querer expresar
algo
es un sentimiento profundo y no habéis
encontrado las palabras o hubiera
gustado reflexionar un poco más antes de
tomar una decisión
pues sí
hay mucha poesía en vosotros y sin
alimentáis puede ayudarte a reflexionar
a ordenar tus ideas a expresarte mejor a
mostrar tus sentimientos más fácilmente
y demostrar tu empatía por los demás
reflexión
empatía
diálogo nos parece que necesitamos
grandes dosis de todo esto
y aún hay más porque también nos puede
ayudar a combatir el miedo a
equivocarnos tan presente por ejemplo en
las aulas
porque pues porque no hay respuestas
erróneas con la poesía
mi hija acaba este año la universidad
y recuerdo que contigo las reuniones con
los profesores en su edad escolar nunca
me dijeron que tuviera que estudiar más
era una buena estudiante pero siempre me
dijeron que tenía que participar más
debía participar más en clase
nos parece que si les acostumbramos
desde bien pequeños a hablar libremente
en torno a un poema a que expresen lo
que quieran porque ninguno estará
equivocado no estaremos combatiendo eso
o nisiquiera aparecerá además si les
acostumbramos a todo eso
si nos acostumbramos a eso
seremos capaces de identificar
mensajes maliciosos tendenciosos y
noticias falsas que circulan libremente
en las redes y también en los medios de
comunicación
y ahora estaréis diciendo sí sí todo
esto está muy bien pero vamos a ver cómo
va a hacer la poesía que consigamos todo
esto como nos va a mostrar el camino de
baldosas amarillas
bueno pues en la universidad de bangor
en reino unido- se dieron cuenta de que
el mismo mecanismo que utilizamos para
intentar descifrar un poema es decir el
pensamiento flexible y la capacidad de
reflexionar sobre múltiples significados
está también presente en nuestro día a
día nos permitirá por ejemplo tomar
decisiones es el mismo mecanismo que
utilizamos
queréis saber qué pasa en nuestro
cerebro cuando escucháis un poema o
leéis un poema
se activan partes de nuestro cerebro que
no se activan en otras situaciones
cuando hace un momento habéis escuchado
los primeros versos de la ilíada
se ha activado partes de tu cerebro que
no se activan ni siquiera cuando estás
escuchando música o cuando estáis viendo
una película que os emociona mucho
porque porque la respuesta neurológica
de la poesía en el cerebro es muy
potente produce mucho más placer a nivel
cerebral
investigadores de instituto max planck
de alemania
concluyeron después de analizar nuestra
respuesta cerebral a la poesía a través
de resonancia electro y otros sistemas
que las palabras y los versos son como
dardos en forma de palabras que van
directos a la parte más emocional de
nuestro cerebro
desatando un auténtico tsunami
no nos emocionamos de manera repentina
como lo hacemos con la música por
ejemplo sino que los picos emocionales
se suelen producir al final del verso al
final de la estrofa y sobre todo al
final del poema
todo esto nos indica que hay algo muy
especial en la forma poética y yo lo
compruebo cada vez que muestro alguno de
los
poemas que he grabado con actores y
actrices porque la respuesta que suelo
tener de gente emocionada
no sabía que me gustaba la poesía no lo
sabía
me gustaría ir un poco más allá y vamos
a volver a la universidad de bangor
porque ellos incluso se atreven a
confirmar que hay algo tan profundo hay
una intuición que les hace concluir que
estamos preparados programados para
reconocer los versos las rimas y los
ritmos de los poetas
y es más lo que han dicho es que
todo ser humano todos vosotros
sois un poeta inconsciente
aunque no seáis conscientes
todos vosotros sois tú eres un poeta
fijaos
pues sí en nuestra vida
nos puede ayudar muchísimo
lo llevamos dentro
estamos preparados para amarla y también
para beneficiarnos de todo lo que tiene
no lo vamos a aprovechar
si los maestros griegos
enseñaban a leer y escribir con los
versos porque no podemos nosotros
recuperar a los poetas como grandes
aliados en las aulas porque no convertir
a un mero assafo a lope a quevedo a
rosalía de castro a beckett a rubén
darío
benedetti estellés a maria beneyto a
lorca
césar vallejo a francisca aguirre
abrines a gamoneda en los ayudantes de
los profesores
parece una utopía pensar así en una
sociedad que ha desterrado las
humanidades no creéis una sociedad que
ha relegado el latín el griego e incluso
la filosofía a la nada una sociedad que
hace esto sólo puede caminar hacia el
abismo de la ignorancia
qué hacemos
seguimos caminando hacia ese abismo os
retomamos la senda que no debimos dejar
nunca
quizá ganó platón
platón que no quería los poetas al cargo
de la formación de la mente de los
jóvenes él pensaba que sólo sus escritos
y enseñanzas eran dignos para ello
quienes llevan el timón de la enseñanza
no se dan cuenta de que la poesía de que
los poetas con sus versos pueden ser
grandes aliados en las aulas y en la
vida en contra de lo que pensaba platón
si las instituciones
se resisten a devolver la poesía al
lugar que le corresponde nosotros
podemos hacerlo
como os estaréis preguntando
poesía en voz alta con vuestros hijos
con vuestros padres con vuestros
hermanos amigos con vuestros alumnos y
hablar del poema si os apetece
buscad a los clásicos y también a los
poetas más jóvenes
vivimos en un momento en el que estamos
rodeados de dispositivos siempre los
llevamos encima en los que tenemos
muchísimo contenido a nuestro alcance
esto es lo que me ha llevado a mí a
crear una colección después sí
audiovisual con la ayuda de actores de
actrices de poetas
una colección que recupera la tradición
oral
y lo he hecho porque pienso que aún
estamos a tiempo de convertirnos en una
sociedad que sea plenamente consciente
de la poesía que lleva dentro y de lo
mucho que le puede aportar
que seamos una sociedad de personas
críticas que se expresen con libertad
que puede mostrar sus sentimientos
libremente y su empatía por los demás
y si me acompañáis en este camino a
medida que os dejéis llevar por la
poesía
descubriréis
cada vez que
encontréis un nuevo autor un nuevo verso
un poema favorito
que como decía el poeta norteamericano
robert penn warren
un poema no es algo que podamos ver sino
que es más bien una luz que nos ilumina
para ver
y lo que nos muestra es
la vida
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]